>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Karen Jaffe: Good
morning everyone.
My name is Karen Jaffe, I'm
head of the Young Readers Center
and I welcome you to the
Star Wars Readers Theater,
a production of Disney Publishing
and Lucas Film Publishing.
It's hosted today by the Young
Readers Center and the Center
for the Book at the
Library of Congress.
Hello to our visiting schools
from the District of Columbia.
Please raise your hands
and let us hear
from you when I call your school.
The Sheraton School, where are you?
Let me hear from you.
Kimball Elementary.
Brent Elementary.
Maury Elementary.
Truesdell Education Campus.
Capitol Hill Day School.
Okay, thank you.
We'd also like to welcome Dina
Sherman from Disney Publishing
and Michael Siglain from
Lucas Film for bringing us,
for bringing us this unique
and original production
which was written by four authors;
Alexandra Bracken, Adam Gidwitz,
Tom Angleberger and Tony DiTerlizzi,
who created-I'm sorry I
mispronounced your name.
His name is DiTerlizzi.
I apologize Tony, who
created four new
and original books on
the Star Wars saga.
If you're a Star Wars fan please
say may the force be with you.
>> May the force be with you.
>> Karen Jaffe: Okay
lastly, one huge thanks
for making this program
possible, from the Center
for the Book John Cole
and Bonnie [inaudible],
from the Young Readers Center
Kaheen [assumed spelling] Mohamad,
Monica Valentine and the very
important volunteers and interns
who work with us so diligently
with so much dedication.
Also a special thanks
to An Open Book
for their generous
support of this program.
Last thing, very important, when the
program is finished and it's time
to leave, please pay attention
to when I call your school name.
As you know we have few isles and
a lot of students so it's important
that you listen for your
school name and your teachers
and chaperones help us
get you out accordingly.
There's a book signing after this
and we want to get our authors
in place and get lines
started for the book signing.
And now it is my great pleasure
to introduce Michael Siglain,
Creative Director,
Lucas Film Publishing.
>> Michael Siglain: Thank you Karen.
Hi everybody.
Thank you so much for
coming out today.
Thank you for the library
of Congress for hosting us.
Thank you to Dina Sherman and
Disney Publishing Worldwide
for getting us all here
and getting you guys here.
You guys are in for
a real treat today.
You may have heard the story of
Star Wars but you've never heard it
like this before, and when you
hear these four authors come out
and read the story, your
minds will be blown.
It'll be as if you're
hearing it for the first time.
The stories that you're going to
hear today is where it all began
and that's why this is so cool.
So without further ado let
me bring out these authors
so they can tell you
the stories themselves.
New York Times Best Selling Authors
Tony DiTerlizzi, there he is,
Alexandra Bracken, there she
is, Mr. Adam Gidwitz, and last
but not least Mr. Tom Angleberger.
There he is.
Alright lady and gentlemen before
we get started I thought it would be
nice if each of you could
introduce yourselves,
tell this fine crowd what you're
known for and what your take is
on these awesome Star Wars books.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Hi guys.
I'm Tony DiTerlizzi.
I've written and illustrated
all kinds of books;
probably most notably the Spiderwick
Chronicles, which I created
with my friend Holly
Black, thank you.
I've done some picture books as
well and I am absolutely honored
to be the author of the Adventures
of Luke Skywalker, Jedi Knight,
which is a picture book that I
put together for younger readers
that uses the artwork of a man
named Ralph McQuarrie who worked
with George Lucas way
back when in the 1970's
to envision what Star
Wars would actually look
like before the films
were even made.
So I was able to have the amazing
task of returning Star Wars back
to words and pictures,
so I hope you like it.
>> Michael Siglain: Awesome.
Thank you Tony.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Hi guys.
I'm Alex Bracken.
I wrote the Y-Series The Darkest
Minds and I am also lucky enough
to be the author of the Star
Wars the New Hope Retelling,
the Princess, the Scoundrel
and the Farm Boy.
And as you could probably guess
from the title I've taken the story
that you guys all know and love
from the film and I've divided
between Leia, Hans and Luke's
perspectives and I delve
in really deep to their
characters and kind
of give you little
sneak peeks and looks
into what they're doing off camera.
So there are a bunch of scenes
that are not included in the film.
So I hope you guys like it.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Hello
everybody, I'm Adam Gidwitz.
I'm the author of A Tale Dark
and Grimm, In a Glass Grimmly
and The Grimm Conclusion, and I've
now written the Empire Strikes Back,
So You Want to Be a Jedi?
And what I do in So You Want to
Be a Jedi is I retell the story
of Empire Strikes Back, you are
Luke, you fight the battle on Hoth,
you are trained by Yoda and you
have to face Vader at the end.
And between each chapter I
have Jedi training lessons
where I teach you how to do
important Jedi skills like meditate
and meditate while balancing
on one foot and other things
and maybe we'll even do a
couple of those here today.
Alright.
>> Tom Angleberger: Hey
I'm Tom Angleberger.
I wrote The Origami Yoda series.
Thanks guys.
That's nice of you.
Yeah, me and origami Yoda we've
been together for a long time,
and one day I got this phone call
and they told me they wanted me
to write a book about
Yoda but with no origami.
So at first I wasn't sure but
then they told me it was going
to be Return of the Jedi, and I
loved the movie Return of the Jedi.
I saw it when I was your age
when it was in the theater
for the first time, just
like you guys are going
to go see Force Awakens and
it's going to blow your mind,
I went to see Return of the
Jedi and it blew my mind.
And so when I got the chance to
write it I just had so much fun
and I tried to pack as much
fun as possible into the book
and I kept packing and packing,
that's why my book is the longest
because I just packed in
everything I loved like the Ewoks
and Jabba the Hut and
I just had so much fun.
I hope if you guys read it that
you'll have a lot of fun too.
>> Michael Siglain: Awesome.
Thank you Tom.
Now that you guys now a little bit
about the authors and a little bit
about their books, we're
going to let them jump
into it, their reader's theater.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: We are.
We're absolutely honored and
excited to be here at the Library
of Congress today to
read for you guys,
and actually though there
are four of us here to read,
it turned out there
were of couple parts
that we needed help with reading.
So there's one part
of this character,
I don't know if you guys have heard
of this guy, his name is Yoda.
Does anyone know who Yoda is?
We actually need someone
to read the part of Yoda.
Is there anyone out here that can
do like a good Yoda impression?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Wow.
So many candidates.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Maybe we
should hold an audition Dina.
Okay.
>> Let's hear your best Yoda.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> We should tell them what to say.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Do or do not.
There is no try.
>> Do or do not.
>> That's pretty good.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Anyone else?
[Multiple speakers]
>> He's getting applause.
>> Okay, alright let's hear it.
>> Do or do not.
There is no try.
>> What do you think guys?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
What do you guys think?
>> I think we've got to try Teddy.
[ Chanting ]
>> Alright Teddy let's hear it.
>> I am Yoda.
>> Pretty good.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: So Dina
maybe what we can do is
by show of applause, no?
Just bring them down?
>> Adam Gidwitz: You're
standing right next to the guys
with the jacket, let's
just bring him
down because he's closest
to you right now.
You did a great job.
Where is he?
Right here.
Everybody did a great job though.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
Everyone did a fantastic job.
>> Tom Angleberger: Now you
know I was telling you guys
that I stuffed a lot of stuff
into my books, well sometimes
when a book gets overstuffed
you use footnotes.
Do you guys know what
a footnote is like?
Right, well for a footnote, we
need somebody to read the footnotes
but wait a minute, it's got
to be something with a really
like a teacher kind of voice.
Are there any teachers here?
[ Cheering ]
Alright they've got
to be a great teacher.
We're looking for a great teacher.
>> I think we've got a start here.
>> Tom Angleberger: Okay.
What's your name?
>> Knowles.
>> Tom Angleberger:
Your name is Moe?
>> Knowles.
>> Tom Angleberger:
Knowles, Mr. Knowles.
Good old Mr. Knowles, and Mr.
Knowles let's hear you read
like a teacher kind of voice thing.
Give us a fact, an interesting fact.
>> It was a dark and stormy night.
>> Tom Angleberger: Oh yes,
yes, yes, that's my guy.
The one I want, yeah.
>> Adam Gidwitz: They've got
both people from their school.
>> Tom Angleberger: Alright hold
on a second, hold on a second guys.
There's one more we need.
You can come on down Mr. Knowles.
We're actually running out of time.
We don't have time to individually
audition people anymore.
If you can do Chewbacca just go
ahead and give me your Chewbacca.
[Inaudible] Alright, alright,
good, good, good, good.
Hold on. Shh.
You're all hired, you're all hired.
When Chewbacca's moment
comes, and you'll know
when Chewbacca's moment comes, when
it's time for Chewbacca it's going
to tell you what Chewbacca
word to say, I want everybody
that just did it and everybody
else too, to do it all at once.
We want a Chewbacca roar okay?
>> Adam Gidwitz: As loud as you can.
>> Tom Angleberger: Let's
just test it out one time,
one more time let's hear
Chewbacca one more time.
[Inaudible] Good, good, good.
Save it for the show.
Good, perfect.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
Alright, Siglain.
>> Michael Siglain: Go for it.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Alright.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: A long time
ago in a galaxy far, far away.
This is a story of good versus
evil, of light dispelling darkness.
This is a story of hope.
It begins on the distant
planet of Tatooine
with a farm boy named
Luke Skywalker.
>> Tom Angleberger: Luke
never knew his parents.
He lived with his Aunt and Uncle in
a farm that harvested precious water
from the dry desert air, and though
he was busy with his many chores
on the moisture farm,
Luke was bored.
He dreamed of exploring
the twinkling frontier
of space beyond the scorching
twin suns of his dustbowl home.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Luke Skywalker
you're in for adventure.
Little did he know that
just beyond the atmosphere
of his little planet an adventure,
his adventure, was beginning.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: It was
known throughout the galaxy
that the fearsome Darth Vader
was the face of the Empire.
Under orders from his master,
Emperor Palpatine, Vader had hunted
down and exterminated all
members of the ancient order
or Jedi Knights except one.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Darth Vader
had seized Princess Leia's starship
and ordered a squadron of
storm troopers to track
down the two escaped
droids, R2D2 and C3PO.
That they had fled to Luke's
planet where they located
that last known Jedi knight.
>> Adam Gidwitz: From R2's eye
came a flickering image of a girl,
though adorned in elegant robes of a
princess, her face was one of worry.
Her recorded voice trembled.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
Help me Obi-Wan Kenobi.
You're my only hope.
The door hissed open and this dark
shape swept in followed closely
by two security officers.
The two men fell into place
on either side of the door.
Their gazes fixed on the ceiling.
For a long terrible
second there is no sound
in the small cell beyond the steady
wheeze of Darth Vader's respirator.
A cold drip of alarm
ran down Leia's back.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: I hope you find
your quarters adequate princess.
>> Alexandra Bracken: No fear,
no breaking, no screaming.
I demand to be released
and given a formal trial.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Spare
me your indignation.
I've neither the time
nor the patience for it.
>> Tom Angleberger: A strange
sound, a beeping that sizzled
through the air like a bolt
of static made the hair
rise on Leia's neck.
Vader stepped aside
allowing a spherical droid
to float in behind him.
It bobbed slightly as
it came toward her.
Its glossy, black exterior
shot through with silver
and punctuated by a red eye light.
>> Alexandra Bracken: What?
No.
>> Tom Angleberger: Leia knew what
it was; an interrogation droid.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: This is
your last chance your highness.
If you will not tell
me where the plans are
and where I'll find
the rebel's fortress,
I will force the answers from you.
>> Tom Angleberger:
There was nowhere to run.
Leia bolted toward the door but
Vader's arms locked around her,
swaying her back into the
interrogation droid's path.
The pain that lanced through her
arm as the needle punctured her skin
and the serum seeped into
her system was unbearable.
And then a voice floated
to her through the clouds.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Your
highness, you're safe.
You can trust me.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Leia
shook her head, turning her face
against something cold,
hard, smooth.
Cell, she was in a
cell, on the, on the,
why couldn't she hold
onto a thought?
Her pulse was pounding
in her ears again.
She pressed her hands against them.
Not safe, not safe, not safe.
>> Adam Gidwitz: I'm
with the rebel alliance.
I need to know what you did
with the Death Star plans.
You must tell me.
You must trust me.
>> Alexandra Bracken: There
was a bad taste in her mouth,
a pounding in her skull, Leia was
so sure she was going to be sick,
she bent at the waist
ignoring the way fire seemed
to burn through her blood.
Words popped like bubbles
in her mind.
Interrogation, Death Star, Vader.
>> Adam Gidwitz: We need them Leia.
Tell me where to find the plans.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
Leave me alone.
Interrogation, Rebels, can't tell
the truth, don't tell the truth.
Antilles, [inaudible]
Alderaan, Senate, Galaxy.
You'll be forced to give
information her instructor had said,
truthful information but it doesn't
have to be current information.
There's always a way to
give a truth that's related
but not the answer they want.
Find a connection.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
Where are the plans?
>> Alexandra Bracken:
I don't have them.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Where are they?
>> Alexandra Bracken:
I don't have them.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
Where did you send them?
Where is the rebel base?
If you do not tell me where to
find the rebels lives will be lost.
All the rebel deaths
will be on your head.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Your father
wants you to trust us.
He wants you to tell us
where to find the rebels.
He's worried about you.
He wants you to come home.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
Alderaan is my home.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Are you a
member of the Rebel Alliance?
>> Alexandra Bracken:
I'm Princess Leia Organa.
I'm the Senator from Alderaan.
>> Tom Angleberger:
And that was the truth.
Vader stepped back watching
her as stilly and silently
as any poisonous snake
about to strike.
He began to turn signaling
something to the security officers.
Leia slumped back against
the metal cot in relief.
They were leaving.
It was over.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Careful.
If you continue to resist,
soon you will be neither.
Luke fled the icy battlefield and
boarded his hidden X-wing fighter
where R2D2 waited for him.
As they flew away, Obi-Wan Kenobi's
voice drifted into Luke's mind.
>> Alexandra Bracken: You will
go to the [inaudible] system.
There, you will learn from Yoda,
the Jedi Master who instructed me.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Luke and R2 arrived
on the boggy planet of Dagobah.
>> Tom Angleberger: I don't know R2.
Seems like a strange place
to find a Jedi Master.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: At dusk
a wizened creature appeared
from the mists.
It was Yoda.
Under Yoda's guidance Luke
began the rigorous practice
of becoming a Jedi,
exercising both body and mind.
>> Adam Gidwitz: What we're going
to do now is we're going
to do a Jedi lesson.
I'm not Yoda but I can teach you a
little bit of how to become a Jedi.
So there's going to be a few
stages to this Jedi lesson.
The first stage is that everybody
in the audience needs to be sitting
in a comfortable, seated position
with both feet on the ground.
If you can't reach then
try as best you can.
I want you to close your eyes.
I want you to start to
breathe calmly and quietly
in through your nose and
out through your nose.
Think of nothing but your breath
going in and out of your nose.
See if you can let this
place where we are,
the people around you just
disappear as you just focus
on the breath going in
and out, in and out.
When you feel calm
and you feel focused,
if you would like to volunteer for
the second stage of the Jedi test,
you may calmly open your eyes and
raise your hand and I will call
on a calm Padawan to do
the next stage of the test.
Sir in the white shirt you
look super calm and ready.
You can put your jacket down
and come up here on the stage.
You can give him a hand.
What's your name?
>> Matheno [assumed spelling]
>> Adam Gidwitz: Mathena?
>> Matheno.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Matheno.
What school do you go to?
>> Maury Elementary.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Alright,
okay, are you ready for this?
>> Yes.
>> Adam Gidwitz: You sure?
>> Okay. I need this right now.
What I'd like you to do
is I want you to face me.
I want you to first regain
that peace you had before.
Close your eyes, try to
breathe in and out, in and out.
When you feel calm and ready
you may open your eyes again.
Ready? I want you to take this
book, I want you to balance it
on your head and I want you to
continue to breathe in and out
of your nose calmly while
it's balanced on your head.
Okay, good, in and out, in and out.
Alright, give him a
round of applause.
Are you ready for the second step?
This is the next stage.
It's getting harder.
Are you ready?
I have brought with me a
bag of my dirty laundry.
I'm going to throw my dirty laundry
at you while you balance that book
on your head, and I want you
to raise your hands and see
if you can prevent the dirty
laundry from hitting you
and knocking the book off your head.
Do you want to do this?
Are you ready?
>> Yes.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Okay, he's ready.
He wants me to throw my
dirty laundry at him.
Alright. Open your eyes.
As it comes you just
try to block it,
but if you swing too hard the
book is going to fall off okay?
Gotta stay calm.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
Gentle, gentle.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Gotta stay calm.
Good, good.
Put it back on.
Keep trying.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Keep going.
>> Adam Gidwitz: He
doesn't let it hit him.
That's good.
Yeah.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Yay!
>> Adam Gidwitz: Give
him a hand everybody.
Nice one. Goodbye.
Thank you.
I'm just going to leave
my socks on the stage.
>> Tom Angleberger:
What is that a hat?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Yeah
that was a dirty hat.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Nicely done.
>> Tom Angleberger: Just a second.
There's an odor problem.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Oh, you're
kicking them over to us, thanks.
>> Tom Angleberger: I'm
sensitive to disgusting odors.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Good work buddy.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: He blocked them.
You guys ready?
>> Alexandra Bracken: Yeah.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: As he
became stronger with the force,
Luke began to have visions.
One of these visions was of Darth
Vader, another foretold the future.
Luke saw a city in the clouds.
His friends Han, Leia and Chewy
were there but they were in pain.
>> Tom Angleberger: I have to go.
I can help them.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Yoda and
Obi Wan tried to stop Luke.
He was not finished
with his training
but Luke had made up his mind.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
That boy is out last hope.
>> No, there is another.
>> He nailed it.
>> Adam Gidwitz: You are
walking through a tunnel.
You see nothing but you can
feel the shake of the space.
The force is curling
around you in the form
of a metallic tube,
but Vader is not here.
You press on.
You emerge into a cluttered,
dark corridor.
Large windows giving out onto the
central reactor core shed a very
dim light.
You reach out with your senses.
Vader is here but he is avoiding
you, muddying the force around you.
A pang of fear slaps your heart.
He is stronger than you are.
>> Alexandra Bracken: And
that's when it hits you
like a barn being thrown by a
sand storm right into your body.
You fall then rise again
throbbing with pain.
A giant piece of machinery has
clattered to the floor at your feet.
You turn to look where it came from
and another crashes into your head.
>> Tom Angleberger:
You are on your knees.
You raise your lightsaber
to protect yourself
but the metal objects
are coming too fast.
Vader is detaching them from walls,
lifting them from the floor
and hurling them at you.
You can see them, you
can't even sense them.
Vader has muddied the
force too much.
You're bleeding, you are
reeling, you are losing.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: And that's
when the biggest one hits you.
You're flying through one of those
large windows glass shattering
around you like rain in a
storm, into the reactor shaft.
There is nothing below you, nothing
for half a kilometer or more.
Time has slowed which
is not necessarily good
because it's merely
giving you time to realize
that you are about to die.
>> Adam Gidwitz: And then
as you fall you realize there is
a gantry platform, a long, thin,
steel catwalk very near you.
You reach out, you are falling
but your hand touches steel,
you grab it, your body snaps
like a fish at the end of a line,
but your hand is still
gripping the steel.
Below you the reactor core
descends into oblivion.
Wind is whipping at your face.
You smell your own sweat and your
legs are swinging over the abyss.
You kick at the air but you cannot
raise yourself onto the platform.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Fear
is overpowering you now.
You look down and back up.
Vader has appeared at the end of the
gantry, towering, dark, enormous.
He is walking toward you.
His steps echo like the
ticking of an enormous clock.
You managed to pull
yourself up onto the gantry.
You climb to your feet which takes
about as much effort
as climbing a mountain.
>> Tom Angleberger:
You ignite your sword.
One last stand you tell
yourself, you can beat him.
You try to feel calm but
you are merely trying
so you do not feel calm, not at all.
Maybe you should listen to Vader.
Maybe you should let your anger out.
Give into it.
But you can't do that.
All you feel is fear.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: He
strides towards you.
Dark, steady, familiar,
and then you leap at him,
your feet leaving the
ground entirely,
your lightsaber leading
like a lance.
He [inaudible].
You land on your feet and
drive your lightsaber at him.
You smell burning flesh.
Gas is hissing somewhere.
You stare.
Vader looks down.
You've hit him on the right arm.
You've wounded him.
You feel surprised, triumphant.
You are a great warrior.
You have done the impossible.
You have wounded Darth Vader.
You are a Jedi.
You have become
>> Adam Gidwitz: His sword
blazes through the air
and cuts your right
hand from your arm.
The pain is blinding and is
instantly eclipsed by your fear.
For as you watch the most
surreal sight you have ever seen,
your own hand tumbling away
from you into the reactor core,
you see tumbling with
it your lightsaber.
And now the pain and
the fear are one
and they are greater
than you; much greater.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
There is no escape Luke.
It is useless to resist.
The rebel alliance
was larger than ever.
Leaders from all over the
galaxy banded together
in a final effort to
defeat the empire.
At the headquarters
of the rebel fleet,
Luke learned that Emperor Palpatine
had been secretly overseeing the
construction of a new Death
Star deadlier than the first.
>> Alexandra Bracken: An
invisible shield protected this new
space station.
A generator located on the
nearby force [inaudible] powered
the shield.
If Luke and his friends deactivate
the shield then the rebel fighters
could strike destroying the Death
Star and the emperor with it.
>> Tom Angleberger: With Han
and Chewy piloting a stolen imperial
shuttle, Luke, Leia, the droids
and the team of rebels attempt
to slip past the new Death Star
and touch down on the
forested moon of Endor.
Chapter 36 in which
the rebel plan begins.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Bring her
out of light speed Chewy.
>> Tom Angleberger: The
blurred stars and cosmic clouds
that they've been watching for
hours freezes and they are looking
at an ominous sight, an immense star
cruiser, one of the biggest ships
in the galaxy just ahead.
Beyond it looms something
far bigger;
the empire's new space
station, the new Death Star.
Now Death Star commander Moff
[inaudible] still doesn't have it
finished and one whole
hemisphere trails off into a mess
of scaffolding and girders.
But even unfinished it still
seems unnaturally large.
Footnote.
>> A dozen planets were stripped
bare just to get the raw materials
to make this second Death Star.
Even now other worlds
are being plundered
to obtain the fuel to power it.
>> Adam Gidwitz: The best
footnote I've ever heard.
>> Tom Angleberger: I should have
had you read the whole thing.
I could have been the footnote and
you could have been the narrator.
That's good.
Okay. It's an insult to the cosmos
that has already thrown off the
rotation of the nearby moon,
but our heroes are not
quite as frightened
as they might be after all.
They've blown up one
of these things before
and this one isn't even working
yet, and yet Leia notices
that Luke seems more
worried than the rest.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Get the nav.
computer to plot us a
course out of here Chewy.
If they don't go for
this we're going to have
to get them here pretty quick.
>> Yrrrggh.
>> Alexandra Bracken: We
have you on screen now.
Please identify.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Shuttle
[inaudible] requesting deactivation
of the deflector shield.
>> Alexandra Bracken: [Inaudible]
transmit the clearance code
for shield passage.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Transmission
commencing.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
Maintain present course
until code verification.
Now we find out if that code
is worth the price we paid.
>> You didn't think the
[inaudible] worked for free did you?
>> Adam Gidwitz: It'll
work, it'll work.
>> Tom Angleberger:
Vader is on that ship.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Don't
get jittery Luke.
There are a lot of command ships,
keep your distance though Chewy,
but don't look like you're
trying to keep your distance.
>> Yrrrggh.
>> Adam Gidwitz: I
don't know, fly natural.
>> Wuggg.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Wuggg.
I want a hug.
The Death Star began vaporizing
entire rebel cruisers in one shot.
Luke felt pain watching the
defeat of his rebel friends.
Anger and hate filled him.
Luke Skywalker felt the power
of the dark side of the force.
With lightning speed he
ignited his lightsaber
and battled Darth Vader once more.
Luke's rage fueled his aggressions.
In time Vader lay defeated
though not dead.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Good.
Your hate has made you powerful.
Now fulfill your destiny and take
your father's place at my side.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Luke looked
down to see his own reflection
in his father's black mask.
>> Tom Angleberger: Never, I'll
never turn to the dark side.
I'm a Jedi like my father before me.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Furious, Emperor
Palpatine conjured the dark power
of the force and struck Luke
with bolts of evil lightning.
The young Jedi fell to the
floor writhing in agony.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: But Luke's
father who still did have a glimmer
of light in his dark existence
could not watch his son be betrayed.
With his last bit of strength
Darth Vader seized the emperor,
lifted him high and thrust
him down a shaft that led
to the core of the Death Star.
Palpatine exploded in a whoosh
of dark, hate-filled energy.
>> Adam Gidwitz: On the surface of
the Death Star the rebels closed in.
In minutes the space
station would be destroyed.
Carrying his battered father Luke
stumbled to an imperial shuttle.
>> Ka-Boom.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Luke's
shuttle rocketed away
from the exploding
Death Star just in time.
A dying Darth Vader asked his son
to remove his helmet and mask.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: You
were right about me Luke.
Tell your sister you were right.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Anakin Skywalker
closed his battle weary eyes
for the last time and
Luke said goodbye.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: No longer
the farm boy from Tatooine,
Luke Skywalker fulfilled
his destiny.
He became a Jedi Knight
and saved the galaxy.
More important, he saved his
father and found his family.
>> The force was with him.
[ Applause ]
>> Tom Angleberger: How about a
big hand for footnote and Yoda?
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Siglain:
That was awesome.
Thank you guys.
We have a little bit of time so what
we thought we would do is open it
up to the audience to see
if anyone had any questions
for our four authors up here.
There's one right there.
>> Adam Gidwitz: I'm just
cleaning up my laundry, sorry.
>> Michael Siglain: And
before you ask questions.
>> Tom Angleberger: I'm sorry too.
>> Michael Siglain: We're not going
to tell you what happens
in The Force Awakens.
>> Okay you have another one?
>> I was going to ask
who was holding Darth Vader's mask
during the video in the trailer.
>> Michael Siglain: I
can't tell you that.
I mean I know of course
but I can't tell you.
>> So we're going to take questions
about the original
movies and the books.
We can't give away any secrets
about The Force Awakens.
>> Michael Siglain: You don't
want me to spoil the movie now.
You've got ten more days.
>> Let's take the quadrant up there.
You want to grab someone?
>> I have a question
about the books.
What inspired you to write them?
>> Adam Gidwitz: What
inspired us to write the books?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Wow.
Good question.
I think Tom you said it best.
>> Tom Angleberger:
Star Trek inspired me.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: We were all
your age when we saw Star Wars.
>> Tom Angleberger: Oh Star Wars.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Star Wars.
>> Tom Angleberger: I meant to say.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Was that a joke?
>> Tom Angleberger: What?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Were you joking?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Were you joking?
>> Tom Angleberger: I'm just trying
to mess with [inaudible] that's all.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
We were all your age
and does anyone here love Star Wars?
Has anyone seen the movies?
That's us.
We are huge Star Wars fans and
so we were greatly inspired
by these original films, and
I know I speak for myself,
probably for all you guys,
it greatly influenced us
as story tellers in our other books.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Next question.
We got a question up there?
>> What was the first
children's book you ever wrote?
>> Adam Gidwitz: First
children's book we ever wrote.
Good question.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Start with me?
I did a book about a boy who loves
Moon Pies called Jimmy Zangwow's
Out-of-This-World Moon-Pie
Adventure.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
It sounds delicious.
>> Tom Angleberger:
Give it up for Moon Pie.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Well thank you.
>> Alexandra Bracken: I wrote a book
about a cursed wizard
called Brightly Woven.
>> Tom Angleberger:
I didn't know that.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Yeah,
that was my first one.
>> Adam Gidwitz: I wrote a book
called A Tale Dark and Grimm
which about the original
Grimm Fairy Tales
which are scary and bloody and dark.
That was my first book.
>> Tom Angleberger: And I wrote,
my first book I wrote was about,
was a book called Horton
Halfpott and,
have you read Horton
Halfpott, that one guy?
You've actually read it?
Yes, one person.
Thanks dude.
Are you just making that
up to make me feel better?
It's alright.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Is that the
book about the exploding sewer pipe?
>> Tom Angleberger: No.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Never mind.
>> Tom Angleberger:
What the heck man.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Another
question right here.
>> What does Darth Vader look
like in the original movies?
>> Adam Gidwitz: What does he
look like in the original movies.
You mean when his mask is taken off?
You did that scene.
>> Tom Angleberger: Right.
I got to do that scene.
I got to write that scene
and what's amazing is
to the viewer it's disgusting.
I mean he's been in that mask for so
many years, he's been badly injured.
>> Alexandra Bracken: He
must smell pretty ripe.
>> Tom Angleberger:
It's really weird.
But so for the viewer
it's really disgusting
but for Luke Skywalker it's
the first chance he's ever had
to look his father in the eyes.
It's his first chance to
ever see what his father is,
so it's a really strange scene.
>> Adam Gidwitz: And he's
like dad, you're ugly.
>> Tom Angleberger: No, no, no.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Then
you put the mask back on.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Sorry dude.
Next question.
>> How many days did it take
to make those four books?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Ask us again.
We couldn't hear.
>> How many days did it take
to make those four books?
>> Adam Gidwitz: How many days did
it take to write the four books?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: A lot of days.
>> Tom Angleberger:
Yeah, a lot of days.
>> Michael Siglain: I think it
took them too many days actually.
>> Adam Gidwitz: It took me
about a year to write my book
and it was not easy because I'm
trying to write a book that is
as exciting as one of my
favorite movies of all time,
so it's not easy to do that.
And you can't just write
what you saw on the screen
because everybody else
saw that, that's boring.
So you've got to find a way to make
it interesting, make it exciting
for a reader in a book, so I think
we all had different approaches
to try to do that and it
took a long time to do.
So it took me a year.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Yeah
it took me a couple months.
>> Tom Angleberger: A couple months?
Man.
>> Adam Gidwitz: She writes fast.
>> Tom Angleberger: Yeah
she's a lot faster than I am.
It took me forever because I
would watch the movie like,
and I would pause it after two
seconds and then write what I saw.
Wait a minute.
Anyway I had a great
time, it was the best.
If it took about eight months,
it was an awesome eight months.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Question
up there right?
>> How long has it taken you; no.
How many books have you made?
>> Adam Gidwitz: How many
books have we each made?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Oh man.
A lot.
>> Tom Angleberger: A bunch.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Like seven.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Four.
>> Tom Angleberger:
I'm up to like 14 now.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Wow.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Over there.
>> You left out, you left
out the part on Endor.
>> Tom Angleberger: Yes.
Let's reenact it right now.
You guys want to be Ewoks?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Yeah.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Let's do it.
>> Tom Angleberger: Can
you guys be Ewoks too?
Because when the Ewoks go to
battle they have a battle cry
and their battle cry is [inaudible].
So I'm going to be an Ewok and when
I raise my fist you guys do the
battle cry, [inaudible].
Yes, yes. We're all Ewoks.
Is that good?
Are you satisfied now?
You satisfied now?
He's satisfied.
>> Adam Gidwitz: That
scene is in the book,
so we just read little
parts of our book.
In the book it's there.
Alright down here we've
got a question.
>> How did Darth Vader turn evil?
>> Adam Gidwitz: How did
Darth Vader turn evil?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
That's a good question.
>> Alexandra Bracken: He gave into
his anger and hatred and fear.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: And fear.
All the things Luke was
battling; anger, fear.
>> Tom Angleberger: He let his anger
take control of him and he let,
when anger and fear took
control of him he fell victim
to the Emperor Palpatine and Emperor
Palpatine led him to the dark side,
even though Yoda was trying to
pull him back to the right side,
Emperor Palpatine was
too strong right then
because of Vader's fear and anger.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Over here.
>> What were your biggest
challenges in writing Star Wars?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Great question.
What were the biggest
challenges in writing Star Wars?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: A lot
of people love Star Wars.
So there's a level of expectation
that we had to try to deliver this,
like Adam said, capture
this excitement in words
or in words and pictures.
It's really tough.
>> Tom Angleberger: Another part
is like a big monster will come
on the screen, in one split
second you see that monster
and you know oh that's
the [inaudible],
it's got these giant teeth, but
to write and describe that is
like three pages to describe
just how big his teeth are.
So that's one reason
it was really tricky.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Like 100 of
Tom's pages are just about teeth.
Most of the book is just teeth.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
Teeth and drool.
>> Tom Angleberger: That's not true.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Over there.
>> Are you going to do
like the Phantom Menace,
Attack of the Clones
and Revenge of the Sith?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Good question.
>> Tom Angleberger: Do
you think we should?
>> Michael Siglain: Yeah,
do you want to see that?
>> Tom Angleberger: Should
we do Phantom Menace?
>> Michael Siglain: Alright.
>> Adam Gidwitz: So the guy
over here, Mike Siglain,
runs the Lucas Film Publishing
and it's his decision whether
we write those books or not.
>> Tom Angleberger: Do you
think he should let one
of us write The Force Awakens?
>> Michael Siglain:
What do you think?
>> Tom Angleberger: Right, me too.
>> Michael Siglain: Alright
you guys have to fight now
to figure out who writes it.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Alright, over here.
>> Mr. Angleberger will you write
another book using origami Yoda?
>> Tom Angleberger: You know I don't
want to take too much time here
but you know my series was
about Dwight and Harvey,
Dwight versus Harvey, and that story
of Dwight and Harvey is over now
but it's possible that there'll be
a new story about different kids
with different characters,
maybe kids like you
that have seen The Force Awakens
and want to make origami based
on the new movie, so
it's possible man.
If I did another book who do you
think should be the cover star?
>> Kylo Ren.
>> Tom Angleberger: Kylo Ren.
Good choice man, great choice.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Alright
question down here.
>> What is your favorite
droid out of all the series?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Favorite droid?
>> Yes.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Good question.
>> And BB-8 included.
>> Adam Gidwitz: BB-8 included.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: What
favorite droid including BB-8.
I love the Gonk droid.
>> Tom Angleberger: Aw dude,
I was going to say Gonk droid.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Gonk droid.
He's just a giant like
lunchbox with legs
and he goes gonk, gonk,
gonk, gonk, gonk.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Who's
your favorite Alex?
>> Alexandra Bracken: Oh
I was going to say IG-88,
he's the bounty hunter,
he's scary, but I love R2.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Yeah I'm going
to go just really basic with R2D2
because I feel like every like
[inaudible] you know all the sounds
that he makes, he's really just like
saying really bad words at people
but nobody understands it.
I think he's cursing
through the whole movie.
>> Tom Angleberger: Well if you're
going to go R2 I'm going to go C3PO.
I love C3PO.
>> Adam Gidwitz: It's
your first choice.
>> Tom Angleberger: He's
underrated and in my book I point
out that the entire Star Wars
saga pivots on C3PO's ability
to translate Ewok, because if he
couldn't have translated Ewok,
everybody would have lost.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Down here.
>> I've got a question for the girl.
How did you make your
voice sound like that?
>> Alexandra Bracken: You
mean Emperor Palpatine?
That one?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: That was good.
>> Alexandra Bracken: You pretend
you're clearing your throat.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Up there.
>> Who did Chewbacca kill?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Who
does Chewbacca kill?
>> Tom Angleberger: Chewbacca is a
pretty deadly warrior and he shoots,
he shoots about half of the
speeder bike guys right?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: Yeah.
>> Adam Gidwitz: And he shoots at
the storm troopers who are trying
to get onto the base on Hoth.
>> What are your favorite
parts in the movie?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Favorite
>> Tony DiTerlizzi:
That's good, that's good.
I still love when Luke looks at
the two suns setting when he's
like wants to leave his home and
he wants to go, go on an adventure
and explore and he
watches the sun sets.
That was very, that meant
a lot to me as a kid.
I grew up down in Florida
and it feels
like we have two suns it's so hot.
I also yearn to leave home.
>> Alexandra Bracken:
You guys know how that is
in this area and the sun.
It's hot. My favorite is still
when they escape the Death Star
and Leia has to save the boys
who are trying to save her.
>> Adam Gidwitz: My favorite is
on [inaudible] when Luke tries
to lift the x-wing out the
swamp with just using the force
and he can't do it, and he says
Yoda you're asking the impossible.
And then Yoda, little Yoda lifts
the whole ship out of the swamp
and Luke says, I don't believe it,
and Yoda says, that is why you fail.
>> Tom Angleberger: I like that one
part where Han Solo says something
and then Chewbacca says
something and it sounds like this
>> Yrrrggh.
>> Tom Angleberger: I just like
hearing them do the Chewbacca sound.
>> Alexandra Bracken: You
guys are pretty great Wookies.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Who's next?
Down here right?
>> How did Darth Vader's voice, I
mean how did his face get all white?
>> Adam Gidwitz: When
his face gets all gross
and white in the movies right?
I think if you keep a giant
metal helmet on for like 30 years
or whatever, you just get like that.
You get no sun exposure.
>> Alexandra Bracken: No sun.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: No suntan.
>> Why is he all battle
damaged and, why's he all hurt?
>> Tom Angleberger: That's
because he and Obi Wan had a fight
on the volcano planet and there
was a lot of lava and Anakin ends
up not only getting beaten by Obi
Wan but also falling into the lava,
so he's pretty badly damaged.
>> Adam Gidwitz: We've got
to keep moving over here now.
Over here.
>> What was the coolest
movie you made?
>> Adam Gidwitz: The
coolest of these movies?
All the Star Wars movies?
>> Alexandra Bracken: Maybe
we should do an audience vote
on which film they like the best.
>> Tom Angleberger: Yeah.
Okay.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Show of hands,
not cheering just show of hands.
>> Tom Angleberger: Raise your hand
if you think Phantom
Menace is the coolest?
Attack of the Clones?
Revenge of the Sith?
The Clone Wars TV show?
A New Hope?
Empire Strikes Back?
Return of the Jedi the book I wrote?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: The
Star Wars Holiday Special?
>> Tom Angleberger:
The Force Awakens?
They love the Force Awakens already.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Alright up here.
Last couple of question right?
Okay.
>> Why did you choose to put
those characters on your books?
>> Adam Gidwitz: Great question.
Why did we choose these
characters for our books?
>> Alexandra Bracken: Mike?
>> Mike Siglain: You
want me to take that?
Sure. Because we wanted
to do something
that hadn't been done before
and we figured for Star Wars,
the way Alex wrote it, is she
made it into three stories;
Princess Leia's story and
then you have Han's story
and then you have Luke's story,
so we wanted to start
with Princess Leia.
For Adam's we said oh we wanted
to, Adam is teaching you how
to be a Jedi, so in between
the story you get a lesson
like he taught up here
about how to be a Jedi
and who's the greatest Jedi of all?
>> Adam Gidwitz: And if you read
the book with your friends you get
to throw your dirty
laundry at your friends
so I highly recommend
reading it together.
>> Michael Siglain: So we put Yoda
on that cover and then we have Luke
and Vader fighting, and then with
Tom's you know beware of the power
of the dark side, it's all
about Darth Vader so we had
to put Vader on top of Tom's.
And for Tony's we did Luke versus
Vader because it's his story,
it's Luke Skywalker's story.
So we hope you like them, we
love them, hope you guys agree.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Alright, last two.
>> Are you guys going to write
more books based on Star Wars?
>> Tom Angleberger: I sure hope so.
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: I hope so too.
>> Tom Angleberger: You guys have
got to read these first though.
>> Alexandra Bracken: Yeah.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Alright
last question.
>> Why did Luke Skywalker go to
Yoda so he can become a Jedi?
>> Adam Gidwitz: I think you
answered your own question.
So he could become a Jedi.
Don't we all want to become a Jedi?
No? You going to become a Sith?
No, neither.
>> Michael Siglain: Before we go,
we've got just one last minute.
I just wanted to, before, you
know, thank you to the Library
of Congress, thank you to
Disney, thank you to you guys.
Very quickly what else
are you guys working on?
Where else could they, you know,
if these kids are interested
in your stories what do you got?
What's coming up?
>> Tony DiTerlizzi: I did a book
about a cat and a dog that live
in Paris France written by Mo
Willems, you may have heard of him,
and I did all the drawings for that,
and it's a book called The
Story of Diva and Flea.
Just came out.
>> Alexandra Bracken: I wrote a
book that's a time travel adventure
called Passenger.
It comes out January
5th so really soon.
>> Adam Gidwitz: I wrote a book,
it takes place in the Middle Ages,
the time of knights and kings
and castle and it's a dark
and scary adventure, and
there may be a dragon in it
that kills people by
farting on them.
And it comes out in
the fall, in September.
>> Tom Angleberger: That's gross.
So I wrote, have you guys heard
about Rocket Raccoon and Groot?
Yeah you guys like them?
I just wrote a book about Rocket
Raccoon and Groot and it's going
to come out this spring and
I wrote it just for you guys.
Adults aren't allowed
to read it at all.
It's totally for you guys.
And Mike do you mind
if I say something?
>> Michael Siglain: Go right ahead.
>> Tom Angleberger: We're here
in the Library of Congress.
You guys like books
as much as we do?
You guys love books?
This is like in the whole world,
in the whole history of mankind,
this is building and the
buildings around it are one
of the greatest repositories,
the greatest collections of books
that have ever been created.
So I thought it might be fitting,
while we were here surrounded
by the books we love if we all
said on the count of three,
may the books be with you.
One, two, three.
>> May the books be with you.
>> Adam Gidwitz: Thank you guys.
You were a great audience.
>> Michael Siglain:
Thank you everybody.
Thank you to the Library
of Congress.
Thank all of you guys.
May be Force be with you.
Have a good day.
Thanks guys.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.